[music playing]
NARRATOR: Lund University,
Sweden, August 27, 2013.
Researchers confirm the
existence of a new element
on the periodic table, created
through nuclear fusion.
They name it Ununpentium,
or element 115.
Although most scientists
still don't know much about
this unique
radioactive component,
it shares commonalities
with plutonium, used
in experimental rocket fuels.
Element 115 has its own
lore in the UFO history.
So this was said to be
an element described
by a gentleman
named Bob Lazar, who
claimed to have worked
just south of Area 51
on an ET flying saucer.
The government is holding
nine alien spacecraft
that propelled by a
modified gravity generator.
It's being-- the work is
being conducted 50 miles south
of Groom Lake, at
that isolated area
only designated as S4, that
at least one of those crafts
operate.
According to what Lazar
said, these alien craft
ran on element 115.
And there's no
evidence that we have
that it's even occurring
naturally anywhere on Earth.
Well, it turns out
that scientists
now claim to have
created element
115 by atomic collisions.
I think this recent
discovery of Ununpentium
really does help us
understand the significance
of Bob Lazar's testimony.
This was a man who was exposed
to a very rare element that
was allegedly part of
the propulsion system
of an extraterrestrial vehicle.
NARRATOR: On December 23,
2015, scientists working
at the University of California
announce the creation
of a new metal that is
strong and lightweight,
but also flexible and resistant
to extremely high temperatures.
What's really exciting about
this material is you don't lose
a lot of its
flexibility, what we call
it's plastic-like properties.
A lot of metals, when
you make them strong,
become very brittle.
So this material has a large
number of applications,
whether it be a car, an
airplane, or a spaceship.
NARRATOR: While this miracle
metal is unlike any alloy
developed before, some believe
its description is actually
familiar and that it may be a
match to the strange material
allegedly retrieved
by Major Jesse
Marcel from the
infamous Roswell crash.
Most of the stuff from
Roswell was extraordinarily
lightweight, very thin,
foil-like material,
very, very strong, but
weighing next to nothing.
That's from people
who handled it.
The UCLA guys are
doing research,
open research more or less,
with the stuff from Roswell.
This material is the beginning
of an entirely new revolution
in materials
science, where we are
now going to be able
to engineer materials
at the molecular level.
And this does appear
to be the fruits
of a long-term, reverse
engineering program, where
those technologies
are being brought
into the corporate sector.
And now, it's become something
that we all take for granted.
[music playing]